David, does Kamala Harris have
a better shot at being president
if Biden does run for reelection in 2004 or
if he does not? There's no way to answer this
question without knowing what twenty twenty
four will look like. I get the gist of the
question. It's unclear if Joe Biden is running
for reelection. He recently said he plans to.
It's my intention that's not exactly I am
running, he might run for reelection in
2024 and if he wins, maybe Comilla would run in
twenty twenty eight. He might not run in 2024,
which would be an opportunity for Kamala Harris
to run. I think that all we can say now is that
being vice president is a good
stepping stone to the presidency.
There's arguably no better stepping stone. Now,
I know tons of you are going to say, David,
look at all the times vice presidents have
run and they lost. Look at Al Gore. Look at
I don't even know, you know, there's all these
instances of vice presidents who ran and, oh,
look at Joe Biden in 2016. He didn't even win the
primary. OK, 15 vice presidents have eventually
become president. Now, they didn't all win
elections. Right. There are other circumstances
as well. So that's like a very high percentage of
compared to any other job. Vice president being a
good stepping stone to president. You know,
at any given time, there are 50 governors,
there's 100 senators, there's one vice president.
And it is historically a good statistical stepping
stone. Statistical stepping stone doesn't mean
that you win every time. So I have no idea whether
you know, the question of whether it's better
for Comilla to to run in twenty twenty four or
twenty twenty eight depends on what's going on. If
Biden has a hugely successful first term and says,
I'm not going to run, it's probably good for
Kamala Harris. If Biden has a very bad first term
and doesn't run, it's probably not a great
opportunity for Kamala Harris. Similarly to
what might be happening in twenty twenty eight,
it's really less about a vice president running
than it is about what are the
circumstances in the country
under that vice president's tenure and what is
the sort of mindset of the country. You know,
Joe Biden maybe would have done better in 2016
had there not been eight years of virulently
racist and xenophobic activation against Barack
Obama, which Biden obviously was associated with
as the vice president. It's very hard
to go back and run any other scenario.
So I tend to just look at history. It even though
many VPs have tried to become president and lost,
there is still no more statistically reliable job
for becoming president of the United States than
being vice president of the United States. And
we will just have to wait and see what happens.
We have a tremendous bonus show for you today.
Get instant access by becoming a member at Join
Pakman Dotcom. We are also here next week. No more
vacation for a little while. We will see you on
Monday if you are not a member. But you should
be. You really should be.